maybe we'd be just better off we gave it
to everybody and then a month oh my god
there is so much misinformation going on
with this novel coronavirus it boggles
my mind and it's causing people to panic
make bad decisions my patients are
confused so I decided to make this video
and take on misinformation by watching
some clips reading some articles with
you and really understanding where the
misinformation comes from we have
contained this I won't say airtight but
pretty close to airtight we've done a
good job in the United States no we did
not contain it no it's not even remotely
close to airtight yes we've made some
steps in the right direction of trying
to quarantine people and we should
applaud our public health professionals
but to say on national television that
this is contained No
especially February 25th my god the
numbers are still going to go up
tremendously in the US as more testing
kits become available so no not airtight
but also still no reason to panic are
you taking this boat too seriously
wearing a mask right now look members of
Congress are human key provisions
we fly through the dirtiest damn
Florence we touch everyone we meet so
fatty was gonna get coronavirus probably
gonna be pondering a little lost for
words here he's wearing a gas mask this
isn't even what we wear in the medical
setting when we're dealing with someone
who has the current virus this has to be
for some kind of shock value and clearly
I'm watching TMZ so he got the nation's
attention you're a law maker you're the
person we look to to give us accurate
information to protect us take off the
gas masks act like a human get educated
on the subject stop with the
misinformation think about how if you
try to quarantine everybody because of
the generic type food now I'm not saying
this is the generic type flu but maybe
we'd be just better off me we gave it to
everybody and then in a month it would
be over because the mortality rate of
this probably isn't gonna be any
different this is what happens when you
have a politician or economist I don't
even know what his position is speak on
a subject that they're not experts in
this is horribly wrong no we shouldn't
just gather everyone up and give them
the novel coronavirus that is a horrible
idea and a horrible sentiment not only
because it's cruel because people are
going to die but it's not scientifically
warranted let me explain yes we don't
quarantine everybody to prevent the
spread of the flu because we have things
to prevent the flu to treat the flu
we have medicines that if you get the
flu we can reduce complication rates we
can shorten the course it's called özil
Tam of ear we also have the flu shot
that if you get it it prevents the
spread of the flu or if you still get
the flu you'll have a milder case for
the novel coronavirus we have no such
thing so we absolutely need to slow this
thing down by quarantine individuals so
that we can get these medications made
approved safety tested do the same thing
with the vaccine so that unnecessarily
we don't cost people their lives the
whole purpose of herd immunity or
community protection is to make sure
everyone gets vaccinated so we can
protect those who can't get vaccinated
now in this case we don't have a vaccine
but we can still provide herd immunity
or community
action by quarantine those who are sick
because yes while me as a healthy 30
year old if I get this novel coronavirus
it looks like my natality rate is gonna
be quite low but for someone like my
father who's aged 65 that's not the same
story what I don't like in life is that
them a very serious thing the football
mentor this opinion is important I don't
understand it I read it understand it
repeat ken could ask you you are exactly
the same role than I am so and it's not
important but famous people what famous
people say no you have to be able to
speak about the things in the right
manner why did it take a football
manager to come on and make the most
rational statement about this novel
coronavirus oh my goodness all it takes
is if you don't know and you're not an
expert allow the experts to speak on it
the last thing I want to see is one more
picture of Gweneth Paltrow wearing a
fancy $200 facemask claiming that that's
how she stays safe because she was in
the movie Contagion and she knows what's
up no that's goop and when I say goop I
meant poop I'm really disappointed in
written media as well it used to mean
something to be a journalist where you
really took on that oath to deliver the
truth to the public so they can make the
best decisions for themselves and lately
what I've been seeing especially on
digital media is websites and websites
specifically that have a really good
reputation create click worthy buzzie
articles that really are incite a panic
and scaring people more than anything
here I'm holding an article from Nat Geo
which was my favorite magazine growing
up as a kid the science didn't really
fueled my passion for learning about the
human body
sorry girls called here's what
coronavirus does to the body already
very clicky okay I'm with it let's see
what it the sub headline is from blood
storms to Honeycomb lungs here's an
organ by organ look at how kovat 19
harms humans okay
okay you're trying to grab attention
okay I'm with it let's see where we go
from here
the disease can cast a storm over the
whole human body
that sounds really scary colvett 19
epidemic has killed more than 1,800
people surpassing the SARS death toll in
a matter of weeks but then they
explained that the death rate for Cova
19 appears to be a fifth of SARS scary
sentence followed by legitimate
scientific quote that's not so scary
last Thursday was nearly a 50% jump
relative to the prior day and Italia has
since increased by another 13,000 Oh
scary oh but this leap reflects a change
in the way Chinese authorities are
diagnosing infections instead of a
massive shift in the scope of the
outbreak if this outbreak continues to
spread there's no telling how harmful it
could become there's so many unknowns
with this virus but to theorize that
everything could be the worst form of
itself doesn't help anybody it fuels
fear panic it's the reason why toilet
paper is off the shelves in so many
countries why hand sanitizers $80 for a
little container on Amazon this is why
and then they get to the meat of the
article where they actually talk about
each organ system and how it's affected
the lungs Ground Zero even if death
doesn't occur some patients survive with
permanent lung damage SARS punched holes
in the lungs giving them a honey cold
like up here into these lesions are
present and those afflicted by novel
coronavirus to 82% of these cases are
mild as we learn more for example where
there has been 150 thousand or so cases
tested in South Korea they found the
fatality rate is 0.6% they're not that
three point four percent at the w-h-o
talked about in China which is to say
that we need to learn more about it but
to talk about it as if it's creating
honeycomb lungs or blood storms or
affecting the stomach because SARS and
MERS affected the stomach why write this
article I don't know what purpose this
serves outside of getting clicks and
trying to get people scared this is not
useful Nat Geo you're not helping anyone
with this there's a reason why I keep
saying alert not anxious in my videos
and it's because we need people to not
panic we need them to be prepared we
need them to be ready for when the
numbers go up because they most
certainly will go up in fact here in the
United States the numbers are going to
skyrocket in the next few
but that's simply because we're testing
people not because there's this new
giant outbreak there's also something to
be said about the media's obsession with
chasing numbers 100,000 confirmed cases
3300 deaths
230 known cases 21 US states 12 people
have died yes numbers are going to go up
this is a virus that spreads no matter
how much we try and quarantine there's
still going to be spread of this virus
the idea is that we try and control it
to the best of our abilities but know
that there will be fluctuations in the
daily numbers that's why I recommend not
looking every single day and not being
scared by headlines that we see on
Twitter that are like oh my god governor
wolf says there are now two confirmed
cases in Pennsylvania there's gonna be a
lot of confirmed cases in Pennsylvania
in the US especially as we get more
testing kits available to the doctors
and nurses on the front lines but that's
okay we should know how many cases are
out there we want to know so we can
properly calculate the low thalya rate
to get more information to study these
people to maybe put them in clinical
trials but the more the media shows
breaking news alert outbreak warning the
more we're going to panic and the more
we're going to make bad decisions with
bad information and I urge the media
please be responsible in your reporting
get a doctor on board get a researcher
on board to talk about what's going on
with this novel coronavirus because when
we have unqualified individuals talk on
this subject
it creates panic patients come in and
take appointments from those who are
truly sick because they want to get
tested for a condition they shouldn't be
tested for so let's ease the
misinformation out of our headlines
let's talk about the facts and let
trusted sources like the CDC and w-h-o
guide us properly as we move forward
throughout this pandemic I put together
a playlist of all my coronavirus videos
right here and I put together a playlist
of my reddit thread videos where doctors
discuss some of their most difficult
cases embarrassing cases and I think
they're both worth a watch which one are
you clicking on to stay happy and
healthy
[Music]